number one I think middle management is
the most difficult but also the most
important job in the world and here's
the reason because when you're in the
front lines it's mostly finite like make
the sale get the plane out on time
beginning middle end right but you have
to have the concept of infinite because
you have to know that it's contributing
to something bigger and you have to know
that it's not just about the sale it's
how you do the sale so that they'll come
back again and tell their friends so
there's a but as you move your way up
the ranks when you get to senior senior
senior it's mostly infinite with a
little bit of finite because you have to
know that the decisions you make have
ripples middle management sucks because
you have to balance both exactly right
and and you you learn to become a
translator and I think the the solution
that often works best is empathy and
honesty right so one of the things I
would recommend is you're focusing on
how do I help the people manage this
influx of difficult and they say we
don't cuz he doesn't appreciate and he
never gives us the chance and he never
says yes and all of this stuff for you
now to turn your attention to him
because there's a good leader you want
to help him grow and you said he's
open-minded ish right so he's a good
person and we can just assume that maybe
he's never had the leadership training
that he needs it's not a bad guy he just
kept getting promoted right
he's already tired no no that's normal
if you're good at your job you get
promoted but you get promoted to do the
job you to lead others who do the job
you used to be he's open to my advice
and he often thanks me and I said you
rather thank Simon but he's not open to
your well that's okay but make it your
own it doesn't have to be mine he
doesn't have to be mine it doesn't
matter whose name is on is on it it's
ridiculous that's fine make it your own
but the point is is I would learn the
technique of effective confrontation
right right I wrote about it I'm going
along no no no I know what do you mean
yeah okay let's change use the effective
confrontation on my husband all the time
he doesn't know it okay that's
manipulation that's different that's
Simon before we get into it so here let
me know I'll tell you really quick what
if I don't effective conversations
effective confrontation always requires
three things we came up with an acronym
for it but remember what the acronym is
but it requires three things right you
have to have you have to be able to
state how you feel o FBI FBI feelings
behavior impact right so you have to say
specifically how you feel you have to do
better than happy sad angry right you
have to say and you could I'll tell you
all the way oh you have to say
specifically the behavior that they did
that that that is caused the feeling and
you have to say the impact if that
behavior continues you cannot make it
generic it has to be specific those
three things can be in any order but
they all have to be there we've gamed it
out with one and two and it does not
work you have to have all three the
order doesn't matter and it goes
something like this
you cannot say you're always late to
meetings
you need to come to meetings on time
otherwise bad things will happen right
because you're making a generic because
they'll say I was at the meeting on time
on Thursday and you'd be like yes yes
you were but in general and that's what
ends up happening it falls apart so you
have to write down the statement so you
know it you have to know it before you
you have to be prepared for this
confrontation so you would say something
like when you showed up to the meeting
late on Thursday even though it's all
the time you pick one when you show up
to the meeting late on Thursday I feel
very disconnected from you and my
concern is if that you continue to show
up late to meetings that this condition
then this the disconnection will grow to
the point where I'll stop trusting you
and then you shut up so you would say to
him when you when you heard that idea
you can say I'm good I'm completely
confused or I'm completely stuck because
on Thursday in the meeting
you said you wanted this and when our
people gave us this you rejected it and
my fear is if you continue to do that
they will stop caring and then you shut
up and then when he says yeah but they
don't understand that or you repeat the
statement and he says yeah but you did
it or you repeat the statement and and
believe it or not that statement works
extremely well to make them start taking
accountability so it's about managing up
[Music]
[Music]